I'm throwing a birthday party for my baby boy Austin.
He's turning 3 and so I'm making him a cake
using ingredients I know and trust are good for him.
I got started in the morning
by sifting my regeneratively farmed wheat flour
and dry ingredients, then got started mixing my wet batter.
Eight backyard eggs thanks to Tuna,
Nicoletta and the others, combined with melted pastries,
butter, and coconut sugar.
Enough to sweeten the cake but not give someone a glucose spike.
Next I made some homemade baking powder
since the store bought varieties always have cornstarch or aluminum.
And then I combined my dry ingredients into the wet batter
and stopped mixing right when it was combined
so not to over mix the batter and make it tough.
I'm making a triple layer cake,
so I used three 8 inch cake pans and buttered them liberally.
There's nothing like cake batter,
especially when it's homemade with good ingredients.
Those baked for 20 minutes
and once they were cold
I did a cake wash using milk and maple syrup to add more moisture.
Next I whipped up the icing,
which I have to say was the hardest part of making a healthy cake
because I don't use powdered sugar.
But after doing this so many times,
I have finally mastered the art of a perfect buttercream frosting
with unrefined maple sugar.
I use as little as I can get away with.
The most exciting part is assembling the cake
Although it's not as easy as it looks,
triple layer icing action.
There's no skipping here. And lastly,
what's the cake without a theme this year?
Essence getting a monster truck cake.
In the past I've normally done die free sprinkles,
but since his obsession right now is cars and trucks,
he's going to get just that.